Once you've figured out the structure of your HTML,
you can start to think about things like semantic tags.
Or tags that not only make sense to the browser, but
also make sense to any humans looking at them.
These include things like Header 1 through 4, indicated by H1,
H2, H3, H4, images, and forms.
For instance, Header one tags are more prominent and
organize larger pieces of information than say H4 tags,
which are going to organizing more specific pieces of information.
When you're working on a page it's important to ask if any text
needs to stand out.
And then if it does, use some semantic tags to style it appropriately.
Which semantic tags would you use to style the red box containing the name at
the top, the blue box containing featured work, and
the three green boxes containing the titles of our projects?
Type your answers in here.